Speaker 1: So this you just have to see to
understand the complete and total disconnect
from reality that has infected yeah. Infected the
Republican Party when it comes to the coronavirus
pandemic. Republican Senator Ron Johnson appeared
on Fox News over the weekend and he was asked,
could you ever get a vaccine behind,
get behind a vaccine mandate?
We know you're not for one right now, but could
you ever get behind the government mandating that
people get a vaccine? And Ron Johnson said, I
mean, it's completely beyond parody. He said, I
could only do that. I could only support a vaccine
mandate if there was a deadly disease spreading.
Now, of course, he means more deadly than covid.
Let's take a look at the video and then discuss.
Speaker 2: You see that if you have this virus
and you spread the virus and you're unvaccinated,
you have a chance of being better chance being
hospitalized. But I don't think you can mandate
someone get vaccinated. I'm pretty sure that
we've never done that before. And was a month ago
when both Kamala Harris and the president said,
I can't force anyone to do it, but Europe is
doing that. Could you ever get behind a vaccine
mandate for everybody? No, not unless there's some
incredibly deadly disease. I mean, much higher
infections, casualty rates we have with covid.
We don't know the final infection fatality rate.
Speaker 1: So he says he could only get behind
a vaccine mandate if there was something really
deadly spreading to which he clearly is referring
to something much deadlier than covid. And then
he later on went on to say, I'm not downplaying
covid, but you know something about the fatality
rate of the flu. He said, now, let's let's break
this down in parts. This hopefully will be useful
to some of you dealing with disinformation in
your local communities, in your households,
even based on the calls I got last week,
the flu case fatality rate, the CFR is about
zero point one percent. The covid case fatality
rate is three point one percent. That's 31
times higher, 31 times higher than the flu.
Now, you might say, wait, David, what do you mean,
three point one percent? I thought that the death
rate of covid was only zero point eight percent.
Remember, we've got different metrics here.
We're talking about the case fatality rate,
that is deaths divided by known cases, known
cases because of the number of unknown and never
tested covid cases for a variety of reasons, it is
believed that the infection fatality rate is zero
point eight percent. But here we're comparing the
case fatality rate of flu and the case fatality
rate of covid, three point one percent for covid,
zero point one percent for flu, 31 times higher.
OK, so that comparison is weird. Then you have
how infectious are they are zero. Which is the or
the are not is a measure of how infectious, how
easily spreadable a condition is the are not for
the flu is somewhere between one and two for covid
the are not was originally believed to be somewhat
higher without taking any mitigation measures. So
probably in the area of two to four and the whole
point of the mitigation measures was try to get
at below one so it stops spreading and the Delta
variant is believed to be way more contagious.
We're still learning, but it could be something
like five to seven. We're not totally sure, but
the Delta variant is dramatically more contagious.
So the flu comparisons all would point to taking
covid really serious, way more deadly and way
more contagious than the flu. Now, of course,
if you say, well, let's I want to compare it to
something like Ebola, something really deadly,
it is absolutely true that Ebola is really deadly.
Ebola kills. The death rate of Ebola really varies
depending on the medical facilities that are
available. It's also a much smaller sample
size. But Ebola's death rate is estimated at 25
to 90 percent of those infected. The infection
fatality rate of Ebola is an average is about 50
percent. Now, a big portion of that is because of
where Ebola happens. Ebola overwhelmingly takes
place in poorer countries where people often end
up dying of shock from fluid loss that. Would
likely be lower if Ebola was only in a country
like the United States because of more advanced
medicine and access to more advanced medicine,
but there's no doubt covid is way, way less deadly
than Ebola, but it's way more contagious. Ebola
is transmitted by bodily fluids and it has an R
not of between one and a half and two and a half
covid and especially the Delta variant are
way more contagious than Ebola because of
how it spreads. So the point here is when
someone like Ron Johnson says, oh, you know,
I think about a vaccine mandate. If we had
a really serious, deadly virus spreading,
what exactly does he mean? How deadly and
how contagious? We have to be asking that,
because when they say, oh, flu, flu. Well, hold on
a second, let's figure that out, because you could
have something that's way more deadly but way less
contagious. And you could have a similar expected
death toll because you're going to have fewer
infections because it doesn't spread as easily
with a higher death rate. And you could have the
same number or more people die. My instinct is
everything I just said isn't even a factor.
When someone like Ron Johnson says this,
my guess is he'll say I would look at a vaccine
mandate if we had a serious disease spreading
and then he would go to him and you would say,
OK, tell us exactly what an impact, what disease
combination of are not and death rate would
qualify as serious in your mind. And my instinct
is he'll move on to the next talking point. I
don't think they actually really know what they're
saying. They're just coming up with something to
not have to be in favor of a vaccine mandate now
and then. If there was a different
situation, he'd come up with a
different reason to oppose it. These guys are
clueless is the point that I'm trying to make